hello everybody as you said my name is
Rafe I'm the manager of the data
engineering team at Etsy were about 20
people we're actually exactly 20 people
and our team is responsible for sec dupe
infrastructure kind of the whole data
pipeline from data collection down to
the Big Data jobs data warehousing
internal analytics tools and all that
stuff tonight I'm going to talk about
about mainly data pipeline stuff and let
me talk a little bit about etsy itself
so etsy is a company I mean people
probably know etsy we're in Brooklyn
were an e-commerce site we sell handmade
goods numbers-wise were over 600
employees probably 150 engineers and we
let's see we did about three 1.3 billion
dollars in GMS in 2013 can't tell you
the 2014 number and data pipeline wise
were ingesting roughly 10,000 events per
second across the data pipeline that I'm
going to talk to you guys about so I'll
move on what this talk is really kind of
about is path dependence and I have
helpful definition which I'm going to
read but I apologize don't read any
other slides and path dependence
basically says that decisions made in
the past limit the options in the
present even if the circumstances under
which those past event decisions were
made are no longer relevant or in other
words we can't upgrade the Hadoop
cluster until we poured all the
cascading JRuby jobs to scalding so so
that kind of like governs everything I'm
going to talk about in this talk and a
little sneak preview I'm going to talk
about where Etsy's original analytics
that came from how handling changes to
the basically changes in the business
kind of prepared us to rebuild that data
pipeline and then of course like how we
how we came to use Kafka so I'm first
I'll talk about some choices that were
made in the very early days of the
analytics stack and kind of the
implications of those so they started
from scratch when they chose to acquire
a two ative which was here's the text
TechCrunch article etsy buys a retail
product company and they gained five new
programmers these are the five new
programmers so they actually threw away
the entire to ative product that's not
what they were interested in what they
needed were people to work on search
applications one was improving search
where i can get at sea which was
extremely rudimentary when they got
there and the other thing that they
needed was a new advertising product
these guys promised they could do that
so they kind of akwa hired them and
brought them in to work on that and this
happened and I think the fall of 2010 so
when they got there what they realized
it before you can work on search you
need real analytics etsy didn't have an
analytics pipeline at that time if
you're going to mess Rumble start
tracking if you're going to show people
ads you actually have to be able to
measure how they're responding to this
stuff and you know they were using
google analytics or whatever before that
and the company just was not ready to be
serious about search because they
weren't really serious about analytics
yet so this was a hurdle for these guys
right they'd come in they're going to
build these new features it's really
cool oh we have no analytics you have to
build that too that was probably a
surprise to them so what they choose
chose to do was build a zero impact
analytic stack they didn't really want
to ask for permission from other people
to do things they didn't want to have to
like rack new servers or do anything
else so Etsy's not a cloud company but
the first analytic stack was actually
cloud-based they they went about they
went about it and here's a little
diagram so all they did was write some
JavaScript that ran in the browser that
served as an event logger they added
some stuff in the web stack to print out
some you know metadata to the page that
could be used by the event logger and
then they just took an image on our CDN
to be downloaded the CDN accumulated
Apache access logs all the metadata
about the events was appended in the
query string due to Euro length limits
actually events were split into multiple
parts and then the CDN ftp these files
to a to s3 every night like from all the
different edge notes on the on the CDN
most of them made up some of them not
there was a little data loss due to like
ftp lag and other crazy things like that
then they had elastic MapReduce jobs
that processed all this stuff put the
data back on s3 and then they actually
wrote a web in point on the etsy website
that the jobs would ping when they were
done and it would go out to s3 and pull
this stuff down and just put it into a
my sequel database so this was like data
pipeline one point oh and and it
honestly like it worked really well you
know we used it for years years before I
got there and but there were what there
was a big legacy effect which was for
events on the website we had a 24-hour
lag and because they never want to
revise visits they waited an extra day
so they could process the entire visit
across from midnight so they basically
just told people if you want to do visit
level analysis you have to wait two days
and oddly enough like working at this
later but this is actually still this
happened in 2010 and we still live by
this decision today we still wait two
days to do visit level analysis which is
actually fine for most everything so
another big choice they made was
cascading JRuby so here's a little
picture of of the stack super simple so
they had Hadoop they used cascading
which is a java library that that that
you know as a layer over MapReduce
that's theoretically more accessible and
then they use this thing that called
cascading that JRuby that was a rapper a
DSL on top of cascading mainly because
and I love this story when they started
their own company they had heard this
guy who was a super productive ruby
developer and there was another guy
there one of the founders he had written
this library in Java for some kind of ad
tech and they want to use bolt they
wanted the Ruby got to be able to Ruby
but they didn't want to throw away this
awesome jar file of ad tech right so
they said JRuby that's the solution to
our problems they ran rails on top of
JRuby and this was their stack at the
old company so when it came time to do
big data stuff they cast about for
something that they could use with JRuby
as well we had pig on the cluster as
well but it was support as well but like
cascading JRuby was what everybody used
so so the other big choice and this is
actually another one of my favorites is
a you know figuring out how to do visit
serialization is hard figuring out how
what the rules around what a visit is is
hard and honestly don't know how they
came to this decision but they looked
and said well Google Analytics sets a
cookie in your browser that has the
visit ID in it it increments it
automatically when the rules for a visit
change every and and handles all that
stuff and that cookie gets sent back
with every request to the etsy website
so as long as we track that cookie we
can just group all the events by that
cookie and bam we have visits so yeah
they just piggybacked on top of Google
Analytics and didn't really worry about
any kind of visit serialization stuff
other than the actual grouping so the
benefits of course were a simpler etl
layer you just group by this key that
someone else gives you all the visits
were computed on the client side in this
google analytics library and
it was super easy to reconcile against
Google Analytics because you're using
the same visit ID in both places so it's
like how do we know if this analytic
stack works well the numbers are roughly
the same as google we're happy with that
that that is sufficient and among other
things like we've been cursed to
reconcile against Google Analytics for
ever since then because people trust it
if it matches google so this is not
directly germane to my talk but but I
want to talk about a little bit books
just because it was clever and I like
clever things so when they went about
went about to start running a/b tests
they realized etsy already had a feature
flag library and not only that but
people were already using it for these
percentage-based ramp ups of features so
you want to roll out some new
infrastructure you rolled out to one
percent five percent ten percent fifty
percent so they just added some some
additional logging so that that print
basically all the feature flags and
their values when you for the event
lager and the event log are logged all
the feature of like settings that were
checked on each page so then they
basically just told people you know if
you're on an experiment you launch it to
a percentage you hold it at that
percentage long enough to get a
statistically valid sample of data and
then boom you have an a/b test like
there's no additional special library
for a be testing or anything like that
just use the config flags that you
already know how to use which made
adoption super easy they didn't have to
write a bunch of new code worked out
really well and you know another big
choice that they made which which made
sense at the time was a they built of
analytic stack around visit level
metrics so there are all sorts of
metrics you can compute for web
analytics you know if you want to
compute engagement metrics or do kind of
cohort analysis all sorts of other stuff
but but for them because they were doing
again search and ads like what they
cared about was you come to the website
you search did you perform a desirable
action after that you know do you buy
something did you favorite something did
you do anything like that they didn't
really care for their purposes whether
you came to the website today and you
came six times over the next week or one
time over the next week what they cared
about was you performed a desirable
transaction in that thing so so we've
always been a really biased toward
toward like computing things at the
visit level which is another thing that
has not aged so well but made complete
sense back in the day so this is so this
is kind of like the picture of Etsy
analytics roughly from 2000
tan or wherever they finished like
rolling this thing out originally and
early to mid 2012 so in 2012 a bunch of
things started happening and we had to
start thinking about like how to react
to these changes keeping two things in
mind one was the analytics that could
not go away there were people running
tons of experiments they're making
decisions based on the data from this
analytic stack and the other thing we've
always had to keep in mind is we have to
basically keep the integrity such that
you can always do year-over-year
comparison so we we've never gotten to a
point where we've been able to say like
oh yeah we've made some awesome changes
to the data stack but don't compare you
know visit counts from july two thousand
thirteen to july two thousand twelve
that would irritate our analyst team and
we don't want to irritate them there are
primary customers so the first big
dilemma we ran into was how do we
instrument the native app so we've got
this javascript event logger it works
pretty well for maybe not as well as we
thought but we were pretty confident at
that time you know how do we instrument
this native app that we're building and
so basically decided on a set of
requirements that might work for this
native app and the first one was that
native app visit should have the same
structure as web visits we didn't want
to have to throw away all the business
logic we didn't code in the library we
used for big data we didn't want to
throw away our jobs so so we basically
wanted to make sure that they had that
same structure and the second thing was
that the native app should use the
existing data pipeline we didn't have to
want to write special ETL for the native
app data we didn't want to what we
didn't want to do anything special so
the point there was that even though
downloading the beacon will be kind of a
weird thing to do from the native apps
we wanted to use that same beacon
infrastructure so it could start at the
very very head of the data pipeline
instead of like somewhere in the middle
and having to reconcile but the other
side of it is that the native apps
should buffer events rather than just
sending them as they happened you know
maybe you're using the etsy app on the
subway and you don't have a connection
or you know maybe maybe your cell
connections really bad and you'd have
massive data loss if you if you tried to
you know send these events in real time
so it was all about buffering so so that
led us to a solution which was we added
a new API endpoint for the native apps
which accepted bundles of events so the
event would uh so the app would buffer
them it would send them up periodically
it sent him to an eight
I in point and then the API endpoint
accepted this bundle of event and then
just iterated over over them one at a
time and downloaded the image from the
beacon servers over and over you know
once or multiple times for each for each
event that had been buffered which I
thought was a pretty clever solution to
the whole problem it made everything
work the same downstream and it was
basically fine the most interesting side
effect of that was this gave us a back
into MIT lager we could use for anything
so prior to that every single event
happened in the front end through
JavaScript and this was really painful
for for a certain variety of events so
like what think about if a user logs out
you're on one page you click on the log
out link and you get redirected to some
other page and the kind of actual logout
action happens in between so it was very
hard to capture with the front end event
lager you could do like a javascript
thing where you ping the event logger on
the click but if the browser left the
page before the before the cliq was you
know before the event was processed it
was thrown away like the data loss was
twenty-five or thirty percent on those
things it just didn't work very well so
having this back into vent lager turned
out to probably probably be as impactful
as having as having this native app
event logging in the first place so so
this was the first thing we did we kind
of set up the iOS stuff we still to be
honest struggle with like getting really
good data from the native apps but but
working on this native app project
shaped a lot of the things we did
subsequently so the other big thing that
kind of happened to us that we had to
that we had to react to was the CD and
diversification project at Etsy and I'll
tell you like I don't want to tell you
guys too much about it there's an
awesome presentation online from some
people on our ops team it's on
SlideShare and you know basically like
you know it's hard to negotiate with a
CDN provider you know as far as they're
concerned they're like you know you're
completely bolding them you can't turn
it off your try your site can't serve
all that traffic and the switching costs
are really high so the ops team went out
and said we're going to make it pretty
easy to switch between providers and
even now we have like a CDN dashboard
and we can you know turn three different
CD and providers on all at various
percentages we can turn one off
completely and rolling this thing out
was really really awesome when we went
to renegotiate our contract with our CD
and provider at the time
you know the word is that that basically
they turn them off when they came to the
office to have the meeting like oh yeah
it turns out we don't really need you
guys anymore in fact you're off right
now so they'll super cool for them and
very exciting we had a big problem which
was that we ran all of our analytics to
our CDN so if we want to be able to turn
any of them off at any time we were
going to be screwed right like it would
go away we don't be seeing a percentage
of things so at that point we migrated
to our own beacon infrastructure we got
a you know four or five crappy servers
that weren't being used for other things
we put Apache on them and suddenly we
had kind of our own front of the data
pipeline instead of doing the CDN thing
and ftp things to s3 we had we had just
some off-the-rack Apache servers they'd
hit a PHP endpoint it like filtered out
some cookies and stuff it wrote the
excess log there and then we actually
use the UNIX logrotate program and cron
as the beginning of our data pipeline so
it just uploaded these files
periodically to s3 again actually that's
still how things work at Etsy that's
basically fine it still kind of kept
this in batch mode at this point we
could have started doing the ETL more
incrementally but we still just went
every night at about the same time we
were rolling at our own Hadoop cluster
internally and this was a function
almost entirely of cost our elastic
MapReduce bill had gotten really really
high such that it seemed to make sense
or it did make sense to go out and
purchase like a 160 node Hadoop cluster
it's now more like 300 nodes but but we
built this thing when we rolled it out
you know the two interesting things to
say here are again like he gave us a lot
more control over everything we throw
away a bunch of cruft e stuff when we
did that we had our own workflow engine
that was also written in JRuby of course
we threw that away and started using uzi
we ported all these jobs to to run on
our to run on this new cluster rather
than the old one we had more data
locality jobs launched faster it was
easier to teach users how to use it we
could build better tooling around it so
this was a you know a huge milestone
basically at the end of 2012 to migrate
from the old cluster to the new one
another thing that happened in fall of
two thousand twelve was that we hire
Dhabi Bryant
who was one of the authors of scalding
so the truth is that cascading JRuby is
really pretty crappy and it was
completely unmaintained we would maybe
make a little patches to it but there
was no community around it or anything
else so we hired a guy who thought he
had written something much better and
indeed had written something much better
and he was not going to wait for us to
make a strategic decision about which
thing to use he just went out and
installed it on our you know in our
development environment for for writing
big data jobs and had his new team which
were basically all new people to etsy
start writing scalding jobs instead of
cascading JRuby jobs for people who
don't know much about etsy this is like
a relatively anti etsy thing to do you
know we like we're big believers in like
have one of everything you know what you
know few data stores not a lot of
different programming languages things
like that so so this was actually like
disruptive in a good way the other thing
that kind of made this a little bit
easier is that we have a bunch of
libraries that under that supported the
cascading that JRuby stuff that were
already written in Scala so we had a
fair amount of Scala knowledge
internally so it made it easy for people
to adopt scalding and it just kind of
happened and I'm going to do this a
second time and say like there's
actually a fantastic presentation about
this by a guy named and McKinley who
used to work at Etsy that goes into like
why scalding performed better and why
people adopted it in all sorts of things
i would encourage everybody he's also
really a funny speaker and I would
encourage to watch it people to watch it
just for that reason really good talk so
so again moving on to the other crazy
things to happen to us we found that the
Google Analytics JavaScript it hurt the
performance of the website especially
because we couldn't load it
asynchronously so the performance team
vedet see we have a performance
engineering team came to us and said
like why you guys you know loading
google analytics jayus you know
synchronously when we could load it
asynchronously clearly asynchronously
like we do with every other third-party
piece of JavaScript on the site and we
were like well we do that because the
event logger that we use for everything
is completely dependent on it so we
can't log events if we don't load GA
that j/s first and so basically like the
points is going to suck until we fix
that and like that's what this next
slide says so we came up with an idea
which was like you know we don't have to
use G
pay for this will create our own cookie
will increment to visit I be just like
we did before will apply the you know
will will increment the visit counts and
do other things just like them and it'll
be perfect will get rid of it and in
probably October of 2012 we're like okay
ready to go we have the new cookie
running we've done all a reconciliation
we're happy and one of the data
engineers was like well don't launch it
today because I'm buying a new house and
have to close on my house it was like
okay that's fine we can wait and then
like we didn't watch it the next day and
then the weekend came and then sometime
you know between him asking it's not to
launch and and you know the next week or
so we realized something which is we had
a big big problem that precluded us from
from doing this so we have these back in
events everyone was using them for all
sorts of things but of course the back
intimates fire on the server then the
ghas loads and then the front end event
loads so as you'll see from this from
this table if you can read it we were
applying the backend events to the wrong
visit because like need sale you to wait
30 minutes to start it if it's 30
minutes has elapsed we start a new visit
they make a request to the server we log
a back into vent gijs is not executed
yet to increment the visit ID or our own
coded not done so hood just stuck them
on the wrong visit it made the visits
look really long it attributed things to
the wrong visits to the website and of
course it was even more problematic if
people landed on a page this for some
reason fired a back end event before
they even fired the Google Analytics
JavaScript so so like this was hugely
problematic and we're like you know not
only does not only does this not work
like Google Analytics isn't really
working for us anymore either so instead
of just launching that thing we had come
up with we spent most of 2013 writing
and reconciling you know rewriting our
whole entire etl layer we had to do it
anyway because we were trying to get rid
of cascading JRuby and we want to
rewrite it in scalding but this turned
out to be a kind of a really painful
project you know there was just tons of
reconciliation to do we started but the
exciting thing about it was that we
realized we're not Google we don't have
to you know use the browser CPU to
calculate when there's a new visit and
apply these rules all we need to do is
stick a browser ID on every event and
then we can apply the visit
serialization logic
in our big data job so so real excited
about this it gives complete control and
the most exciting thing about it was
that if we rised if we found any ETO
bugs we could actually backfill to the
beginning of time to the beginning of
when we roll this out because of course
we controlled all the visit logic and
you know we thought social school when
we sold everyone on it and basically
this is what it led to always be
backfilling we find ETL bugs all the
time and then we spend like three weeks
back filling all the visits to the epoch
of this new visit system which is July
first 2013 so yeah so that so in the end
it was worth it but but it's also causes
some pain that we have not have
predicted like taking control of some of
the components of the system has really
led to has really led to have it you
know the more control you have basically
the more flexibility you have and the
less people are willing to lower their
standards when GA control all of our
visits like they just put up with crappy
data when we control when we controlled
it ourselves they were no longer willing
to do so so another kind of crazy thing
happened right as we were about to
launch this new etl we're really excited
about it and and someone added a back
end page view event so basically what
that meant was when someone landed on
the most popular page on the site it
fired a back an event and this is what
happened we invited the robot army to
our analytics stack prior to that we had
a really hard rule on bakit events which
was they could only be fired for things
that basically were not just a straight
page download because we knew this would
happen like all of a sudden there would
be robots you know we'd every hit from
the Googlebot would be a new visit to
the site so sure enough some day in
September of 2013 we come to work I look
at the visits we have like three or four
times as many visits as we'd had two
days ago to the website and it's like
okay this is this is a new thing for us
what happened sure enough this guy had
added this new event and and like it
kind of broke everything to have this
back in page view event unfortunately
you know we controlled our own ETL so we
just filtered it out and brought the
visits back to normal but the big
realization there was that was that we
needed these back and page view events
for a/b tests the reason he had added it
is that
so most of our ABT tests actually bucket
the users on the server we do a config
check it assigns them to one bucket or
another and then we would print out the
information about their a/b tests to the
client and then the JavaScript logger
would log which a/b tests they were in
so if you ever launched an experiment
where the two variants we're different
page wait you got different page you get
different data loss from each variant so
the bucketing on the server would be say
you know 6040 which is what you'd expect
but your experiment would be 62-38 or
6337 and it was like throw away all your
experiment data fix the bucketing issue
and start over so this was a huge
problem this experiment bucketing so we
kind of instead of launching this new
ETL that we were excited about we spent
two more months writing a bot filter
that actually worked that turns out to
be quite a lot of work but in the end at
the end of the year we had launched this
new ETL and more than that over this
basically a year and a half to two years
we had a we've done done basically
rewritten huge chunks of the stack so we
controlled the beacon infrastructure
that used to be on the CD ends we had
ported all of our most of our jobs from
scalding to cascading that JRuby and
weren't writing any new ones we had our
own Hadoop cluster we had the ETL while
straightened out so we had a ton of we
had a ton of control that we didn't have
before we had a lot fewer external
dependencies and so then at the
beginning to thousand fourteen it was
kind of like okay what's the next phase
in this thing what have we learned over
this past year and a half that will
enable us to kind of take the next steps
so we came out with a new project called
event pipe and had a few had a few
requirements kind of based on what we
had learned in the pain we'd suffered
over this time so the first one was we
really want to use post real quick post
rather than multiple get requests for
these things when the get request split
the events up and apart basically in two
parts it really upped the data loss I
was kind of hard to deal with the job
that merged them all together was kind
of messy so we just wanted to use post
it's simpler in kind of a cleaner
solution and likewise rather than having
these huge long query strings we wanted
to use JSON so that when you actually
looked at the structure of the beacon
that people downloaded you could see
what was in it rather than like thinking
about ampersands and URL encoding and
all the other crazy stuff that grey
strings involved
the third thing we really want to do was
validate the beacon data before it
entered the data pipeline so
traditionally we have done tons and tons
of a defensive programming at every
level of sac in the ETL layer and
individual jobs in other places you know
it's the web data is dirty you expect to
get an integer and you get like five
hundred bytes of JavaScript from some
random spot on the page and like then a
job that's supposed to run every night
fails because of this like data
validation so so we thought gosh if we
can validate these things before we ever
even let them into the dated pipeline
it'll make life easier prior to a prior
to this project we stored all of our
beacon data in the Apache in the native
app ecchi log file format that it was a
that it came in as this is not terribly
efficient again like it's not it's you
know it's a pain so we wanted to use a
real binary serialization format for
that and then we also wanted to use
confident like this is the one specific
piece of technology we picked out to
kind of escape from the batch paradigm
like even though our batches were much
smaller we're saving these little files
and log rotating them out still very
bachy we thought that you know Kafka was
kind of the technology at the moment and
we could completely get rid of the batch
paradigm and process things in any pace
we wanted once they were in Kafka so and
finally we want to eliminate the
individual beacon servers as points of
failure so this is the thing that
actually happened you know the beacons
would would accumulate event and then I
mean the beacon service would accumulate
beacons and upload them on this kind of
cron job basis they didn't even have
raid so like if the hard drive and one
of them died you just lost all the
unloaded data another thing that
happened one time is someone made a bug
in a shell script that was down
uploading things to Hadoop from the from
the machines it was uploading them and
deleting them uploading them and
deleting them except that it wasn't
really uploading the error checking was
wrong in the bash script because they
had put an echo in and it was checking
like the return value of the command so
it checked the return by you the echo
command rather than the upload command
the error checking failed and like it
just deleted two days of data before
they could hit ctrl-c see ya like this
is this is the thing that happens uh you
know so we thought about okay how do we
you know so that we came out the
requirements let's use Kafka it will
solve all these problems
and we're super excited you know we're
ready to wear a to go we've got Kafka in
the pipe and we're about ready to work
on this new stuff rewrote the event
loggers and what we found was a there's
like this big basically impedance
mismatch between our beacon handler
which was a kind of PHP script running
on apache and and Kafka which was like
Kafka especially cuffed a 0.8 a little
bit expensive to connect to you have to
talk to zookeeper first and do all these
other things and of course PHP just
wants to reconnect to everything on
every request so I was a actually a met
Pete for drinks at the square office and
I met a guy who used to work at tumblr
and then worked at square and and he
told me like yeah your plan is not going
to work because your PHP servers are
going to you know do s Kafka and
everything's going to melt down and
you're screwed and I was like well
that's unfortunate and and we kind of
were in a little bit of a jam anyway
because there was no Kafka 0.8 client
for PHP anyway so we were like we're
going to write one ourselves are we
gonna do this other thing so what we
wound up doing instead was that we wrote
our own server and go which is what
people do these days and and you know it
C realizes the beacons into thrift and
then it sends him onto Kafka so the
reason that we so the reason that we
chose thrift was basically like
dependency juggling we couldn't we
wanted use Avro but we couldn't find a
good Avro library for go or maybe we can
find a good one for some for node we
played with node before we use go
because that's the other thing people do
and and we wound up writing it and go so
I think we could use a bro now anyway so
C realizes the beacons and thrift
validates him against the thrift schema
and then sends them onto Kafka and and
like this solution we are super super
happy with it we already ramped it up we
ran all of our traffic like we so
basically we sent ten percent of the
traffic to the website on cyber monday
through one of the beacon nodes that's
running this new server and go and like
it no stutters no nothing so so from a
from a scalability perspective like you
know everybody jokes about going
scalability but it's been really really
good and it's like it's not like we're
expert go programmers this is somebody's
first go project and even then like it
works pretty well and part of the reason
for that is that we still use apache for
SSL termination so we have a bunch of
beak
that come in via ssl and we just use mod
proxy to send the traffic to the go
thing and let Apache do what it's good
at so so basically where we are now is
we have this whole pipeline up and
running we have our full production
kafka cluster we have the ETL that's
pulling down the data from Kafka and
processing it but because we're not
through with data reconciliation it's
not live yet like we're really hoping I
would have left to a company's talking
but like and it's live but it's not
quite live it's it's it's all running
but we have to figure out to make sure
again that all the visits lineup as they
did before and we're not losing a bunch
of data and stuff like that so hopefully
in the next month or so that will all be
done and all of Etsy's data will be at
least our analytics data will be flowing
through Kafka and and you know we'll
finally kind of at least theoretically
be away from the batch paradigm that
we've been living with now for like five
years so I'll talk a little bit about
about what's still to come the first one
was something i just mentioned which is
a real ish time etl like we don't really
need it down to the second and things
like that but it would be nice to at
least be able to compute operational
metrics same day same hour or something
like that and relatedly we also want to
build out some real streaming in
infrastructure so so right now we're
still on Hadoop we're actually still on
Hadoop one so one of the many casualties
of using cascading that JRuby is that it
is like Titus to an old version of
cascading and an old version of Hadoop
and an old version of this an old
version of that so in January we'll have
all of our cascading that jruby legacy
job supported will be upgrading to like
see dh5 some modern stuff yarn and then
we can start exploring like new new
tenants on the Hadoop cluster and things
like that but yeah we're like still in
kind of Paleolithic world of Hadoop
etete see thus far mainly because of
like this huge tall pile of dependencies
that are unpleasant I think one of the
things that's blocking us from upgrading
some things now is that people are using
a specific version of algebra so it's
blocking it scowling upgrade like
dependency suck so the other thing is
offline processing for more products one
of the other interesting things like
probably the biggest cost of this big
24-hour delay on events in 48-hour
latency on visits has been that there
are other products at Etsy that our data
products they just can't live with that
kind of latency so people have written
their own completely separate datastax
all the way from a log collection down
to processing down to long-term storage
that don't use our analytic stack
because of this delay so theoretically
we can unify all those products onto one
stack once we've got a once we have a
once we have like a low low latency
answer for people so I'm really excited
about kind of providing the
infrastructure for more products and
unifying the infrastructure for all
these products into one thing and the
other thing that maybe isn't surprising
but as interesting is that there are
turns out there are a lot of things you
can use kafka for so once you've built
one coffee cluster and you have a team
that knows how to use Kafka people start
kind of coming out of the woods and
being like oh yeah we have a thing that
involves you know shipping events or you
know shipping these messages from one
system to another so it's been kind of
interesting even though we're not fully
in production yet we're already talking
to a lot of teams who have projects next
year that can leverage this new
infrastructure and finally to wrap up I
have a couple of takeaways the first is
probably pretty obvious which is that
every choice you make has long-term
implications when they put the beacon on
the CDN I doubt they said in five years
we'll still be waiting 24 hours for
event data but like that's the standard
they said then people got accustomed to
it so there was no pressure to speed
things up it was easy to make things
keep making things work the same way and
so what do you know here we are it's
about to be 2015 and we're planning for
next year to potentially lower this to
Lahore this latency and the other one
that I think this may be a little bit
more optimistic is that fixing stuff
creates new opportunities when we tried
to figure out how to add event log into
the native iOS app we didn't say worth
the beginning of a road that leads to
use of kafka thing that didn't even
exist yet but really like that was the
first step on that road or when when
they did the CD into perspicacious
project and said you guys are going to
have to build your own beacon
infrastructure we didn't you know we
didn't really think about what that
meant either but it meant like bringing
some things in-house having a lot more
control over stuff so it was really cool
like and we kind of stopped and took
stock and said okay now that weed
control these things what can we do with
it and that has worked out really well
for us so those are basically my two
takeaways you know here's the final
slide thanks everybody
and thanks Spotify for host Gnaeus do we
do people take questions thanks hey um I
was wondering how big are your events
are actually going into Kafka if you're
running cop-con bare metal and how many
instances of Kafka are you running oh
sure sure so oh yeah okay now can talk
so the first question is how big are the
events they probably hash I just saw a
distribution of the sizes today because
therefore they were making some go
optimization and did some benchmarking i
can say that in the olden days I think
we cut so when we did the the old events
they were probably all on average maybe
five or six kilobytes mainly because
like the a B all the a/b tests that are
for every event are there just a long
list of them they take up a lot of space
we don't store them efficiently in any
way so yeah like five or 6k probably the
next question was doing running on bare
metal the answer to that is yes etsy
basically runs everything on bare metal
so when it came time to do our real
kafka project we went to pc mall and
ordered a bunch of PCs and like a rat
someone racked them and put them in
there and we're running it on Hadoop
class machines and and we sighs the
cluster basically to hold what we expect
to be a week of event data at some date
in the future so maybe we over so
respect it a little bit but but you know
we want to make absolutely sure that if
the Hadoop cluster went away for a week
which would be disasterous and hopefully
will never happen we wouldn't have to
throw away data in Kafka and was that
all three oh yeah so we're we're running
we're running cough gone 20 hardware
nodes 20 hardware nodes and we're
running copy to 0.8 so that we have the
replication across the cluster
Thanks so your takeaways really struck a
chord with me in particular the first
one every choice you make has long-term
implications and I just I wanted to ask
I feel like some people would hear that
and say oh we need to we need to be
careful we need to take more time and
think more thoughtfully and be you know
think things more through and think
about what the long-term implications
are and some people would say well it's
just the cost doing business you just
have to you can know about it and that's
nice but really just have to accept it
and if you move fast you don't have time
to think everything through and just you
know just be aware of it so where do you
fall yeah so where I fall is completely
on the latter half that I think
basically the long-term implications
what they were doing were more
completely unpredictable right they had
a problem they need to solve right away
the problem they did solve their problem
right away and went on like long before
we fix any of these things they did
launch the new search ranking system and
it performed incredibly well they
launched their new ed products which was
great for etsy so they completely
fulfilled their own goal and they got
the whole company sort of invested in
the idea of running a be testing
themselves so so not only were their
downstream projects and massive success
but really they're analytics project was
a massive success and I think had they
waited you know it's been a year
building the ideal at the time stack it
probably wouldn't have been that much
better honestly like there was no Kafka
at that time you know Hadoop one was
still Hadoop one and all those things so
and I think generally is as a matter of
philosophy like we prefer to let people
go fast maybe make some messes and then
we have a data engineering team to kind
of help clean up those messes and kind
of maintain velocity Emma I'm just a
huge fan I'd always rather be shipping
things and have velocity than sitting
around planning I got you know if I can
plan or i can do work I'd rather do work
and like even if its work to make up for
the fact that we didn't plan honestly
yeah okay thanks
is your thrift Kafka interconnect either
now or in the future going to be open
source stirs it to specific to your use
case no actually we would love to open
sources so the nice thing is it's pretty
standalone and there's some interesting
little bits about it like you know it
has some cool things like you can
gracefully restart it and it doesn't
lose data like it passes to suck it off
to the restarted thing and some other
stuff that was actually really hard to
do so we'd absolutely love to open
source it I think the hard part is going
to be figuring out exactly so so
obviously right now it works with the
generated code from the schema that we
use and like I know people don't want to
use our beacon schema that would be
crazy it's it's like fairly specific to
us but if we can figure out a good way
to like let people plug their own
schemas in there will absolutely open
source it like you know because it's not
really tight that's the infrastructure
in any other meaningful way thank you
what's your partitioning logic for the
events and what's your replication
factor so the replication factor
basically everything is replicated to
three nodes and what is our partitioning
scheme I mean so we have a browser ID
attached to every event if i'm not
mistaken we're basically hashing that
using that to partition don't don't
quote me on that even though it's on
tape and stuff someone on the team could
tell you exactly what it is but I think
it's hashing the browser idea just a
related question since you're using mod
proxy with Apache with sense events to
your trip service are you flushing to
disk if your trip services aren't
reachable or are you offering or
something at the watch yet that will
probably be version 1.1 so initially it
was just like a fire-and-forget if it
couldn't talk to Kafka it just threw it
away now we're buffering in memory but
like if you filled up memory it would
start throwing things away and yeah we
know that like buffering to disk is
something we ought to do but but you
know it's still more resilient than what
we had so we're sort of like going you
know making a mess in going forward and
we'll worry about like that level of
resilience soon
you guys I mean how many different
topics you running with would you have
any strategy in terms of how you split
events up by topic or so right now we
just have two topics one topic is for
beacons and the other one is for invalid
beacons so basically if we can't
serialize a beacon to to the thrift
schema for beacons we just put it in in
a really simple thrift schema that that
has a JSON blob in it and then we're
probably that will probably be our first
streaming analytics application is to
watch the invalid beacons topic and then
alert if the if the volume goes up or
alert on specific things it's a really
good it's a really good thing for
streaming because we don't want to wait
for an answer on that and it's
relatively simple to understand so so
that's kind of where we're headed with
that but yeah we'd certainly have
requests to add more topics to the
cluster and then we kind of have to
balance like you know how much space is
distant going to take how much you know
how much runway do we lose on the like
beacon queuing by adding new things to
the cluster and how many more notes do
we need to add to kind of be at a level
of confidence so and then I think the
other big question we're kind of looking
at is you know is it better to have
multiple kafka clusters that each serve
you know it's a specific topic so that
you have a lot of control or is it
better to have multiple kafka clusters
so that you're so things don't stomp on
each other we don't know the answer to
that one yet we're kind of just getting
started
yeah sorry this is a bit off topic but
what software stack does etsy use oh
sure uh so etsy traditionally has been a
PHP shop and buy traditionally I mean
we're still a PHP shop so basically
everything web facing at EDC is a PHP
app we use some other languages
internally for real specific things but
you know etsy is also very much invested
in like one code base when you push
through to play button it actually
deploys all the internal and external
apps and it's all in PHP so so yeah PHP
I mean PHP great alright thanks again
everybody thank you so much for talking